now i think if team usa basketball
loses
the nba champions can no longer call
themselves the world champions
i think that's valid and they can no
longer call themselves the world
champions
until we win a world championship
minimum or the olympics
i think olympics not all that world
championship here's the reason why it's
good
because this is gonna incentivize the
best players in the nba
to play for the olympic squad so they
can call themselves world champs
when they win the nba championship this
is how you get lebron to go play
this is how you get kawhi to go play you
don't want to win though little american
championship
you want to win the world champion chip
you want to be world champions
can you explain the world champion thing
because i pushed back on this when we
were talking about before but i was like
it's stupid that they call a world
champion in the first place because
they're playing in america they don't
play yeah but if you always had the gold
you always knew what time it was you
always knew we're the best who gives a
[ __ ] yeah we're the best
and we have the best players from around
the world well that's the thing and and
that's consistent so technically you are
the world champion because you're
you know beating the best players from
around the world because all of them are
playing in america but
i don't like this [ __ ] where we get like
a [ __ ] bronze in the olympic it's
pathetic
especially if it's one of our sports we
might not even get that this year no no
that that's true
son we lost to france yeah yeah yeah
we lost to france we lost a lead to
france [ __ ] nicholas batoom yeah yeah
yeah we felt bad for the black soccer
players so he's like ah let's just give
him we don't know who the black soccer
players are
i do i know yeah
[Laughter]
he can't take the penalty kick again
yeah i didn't get the joke now i get it
see y'all are dumb it's not funny
because y'all are dumb
anyway but yeah this is alex new thing
he just doesn't laugh
that's what he was doing to me the whole
i know
kind of racist thing yeah i know i think
i'm not talking about vala
look at that dog he's sandbagging bro i
just laughed at that dude you look like
peaky grinders
okay so uh team usa absolutely pathetic
you can't lose to any other country in
basketball son
we lost we're one in three it's it's
embarrassing dog
it's embarrassing and the good
nigerians aren't even playing on the
team they're good nigerian is greek
yes nigerian is greek can we name the
nigerians that are on the team
can you name a nigerian name in nigerian
that plays in the nba no that's on that
team you can't no i can't how the [ __ ]
do we lose to that team
and don't tell me it's because devin
booker wasn't there drew holliday wasn't
there yeah get the [ __ ] out of here kd
stop losing isn't bam isn't he nigerian
no he's american team dog
like he's a nigerian descent and he's on
our team yeah damn adebayo whatever his
name is yeah
even the best nigerians aren't playing
on team nigeria we're still [ __ ]
losing dude
we lost to australia yeah that's white
people so
i guess the question whites bro there's
a thing you can't lose to white you see
this in sports though
right we're like what canada will invent
how [ __ ] cocky is now that france
beat america
this is embarrassing go on go on we see
this in sports what
we see is in sports yeah [ __ ] him dude
[ __ ] this guy god basically um we see
the sports where like so like the
country that invents it will body for a
bunch of years and then everyone kind of
starts catching up
like it happened with like hockey where
they invent hockey and then they start
getting bodied
england invents cricket and then they
start getting bodied is basketball just
in the twilight of america
ever compare america to england or
canada
ever again you [ __ ] french [ __ ] i
mean that since
america might be this is basketball
twice no no no no everyone's catching up
cut that [ __ ] out now we have so much
like anti-american sentiment from over
there dude
yeah what is that yeah you guys sucker
and you
all of a sudden france gets one victory
on america like instant it's 12.
france might be the next great
basketball superstars
might be the best you need a children
michael petrus bro you remember him
yeah the jordan stopper no the kobe
stopper yeah yeah
yeah yeah french don't make the jokes
don't make the jokes
don't make the jokes okay keep it moving
uh-huh
we're not making jokes about kobe
stoppers no reuben patterson called
himself the kobe stopper
so did petrus oh well i don't think he
just called himself that i think we we
thought he was
speaking he speaks pure only french pure
franchise he just looks like you don't
speak english
um listen guys all i gotta say is it's
absolutely embarrassing like i was like
rage tweeting like i i was tweeting
in where like i wanted someone to
retweet it so that kd would see it
like that that i i wanted that badly
well
andrew was on it dude i was so pissed i
hadn't seen him tweet emotionally like
this about sports
since the next game he gave up on the
knicks yeah it hasn't happened
yeah dude it is it is bad it was really
bad did you watch any of the games
i don't even tweet emotionally like
because that's what gets you in trouble
yeah yeah yeah i was so passionate i
said don't let them back in america i
think if they don't get the gold medal
they don't get let back in america
stay in tokyo forever stay in the
airport like tom hanks
but you're not allowed back on american
soil like actual america
if you don't get the gold medal until
the next time around and then you're
going to win that gold medal
what if they don't even meddle
i i can't even begin i can't even begin
to have this conversation
it would be so truly embarrassing and
it's only embarrassing because of how
little respect i have for other
countries right like if i actually
respected other countries
then i'd be like oh this is some
competition and we'll see what happens
but since i have no respect for any of
the other countries that are competing
in basketball
uh it would be such a massive shot to my
ego that i can't fathom it happening
but i remember when i was in europe i
would walk up to basketball courts and
i'd just call next even if i didn't have
necks
because i was like you're lucky you get
to play against me buddy you're in spain
spanking hoop
son i would i would poop in spain and i
would just go yo i got next
it doesn't matter what you guys think
you get to play with an american
i felt i felt like being black it's like
i feel like being black around white
people
that's what it was like to the rucker
say again like when kobe went to the
rucker no he just goes yeah yeah
it's like it doesn't matter who's
playing kobe said let's go it's my time
it's my time guys i'll teach you how to
not dribble up and down like it's a
yo-yo
that's how i i imagine like europeans
playing basketball up and down dribbles
like bob cousy playing for the celtics
back in the day yeah and the fact that
we're getting
washed yeah by these teams by australia
how do they even win the gold
what do you mean i mean you beat all the
do you think they will what they're one
and three do you really think they're
gonna
they gotta they gotta beat iran they're
playing a role we got [ __ ]
indian barbara walters over here with
this line of questioning
do you think they will yes i'm thinking
they will they're not
i'm telling you they're not gonna they
have to it's called a leading question
you know i mean
i see what you're saying no they have to
they must they're playing iran on the
28th they're playing what
iran they're playing uh the country of
iran they're not playing iran
yeah dude if we lose to iran they won't
lose food
and then they play the czech republic
they played a good team
uh in their like third exhibition game
and then they they ran it up that was
the game i saw where i was like oh
they're going to be fine they're going
to figure it out
yeah and then france they lost they blew
a big lead at the end of the game
completely stopped missing their shots
they don't understand how to play feeble
ball they
they're used to flopping and getting
calls that's not happening i think the
ball is different
so all these people but the ball is
different all this kind of stuff like
that like
maybe it is but there's no excuses
you're you're playing teams that aren't
america
do we understand what's going on here
it's high school kids when your best pro
can't get on your team nicholas batum
isn't getting real burned anywhere
i mean he got time but it was like just
trying to [ __ ] things up you can should
be
great when eric fournier and his
hairline is busting your ass
that pathetic [ __ ] hairline that
could only be accepted in france where
they don't care about the way people
look because you have interesting
theories about love and whatever [ __ ]
that they care about when that's your
best guy and he's
busting your ass and talking that [ __ ]
where's your pride bro
is this like a black lives matter
protest like what's happening
what is what is the end goal here is
this the new taking the knee
you just lose in the [ __ ] olympics
with the flag draped around your
shoulders
what's going on what do we need to do
wait so the first two games they lost
that was still during like the
qualifying [ __ ] so they didn't take
those seriously we we
don't we're only only zero and one
and then we have to i believe we're zero
and one only zero
we have no ways holy we're winless
you're
winning this out cannot lose to
countries that we give money to so that
people can eat
yeah if we are giving foreign aid i feel
you i feel but the brackets take back
the brexit different groups no more
foreign no there's no more foreign aid
i'm sorry
this you got pathetic you sound i'm just
no but
we're actually doing just fine
mathematically we're not eliminated from
anything
it's like when teams just sail it in and
then the problem
[Laughter]
whatever and then they get to the
playoffs and then they just
uh then they take the [ __ ] seriously so
right now who are those teams that win
nah but like happy in the nba like
during the season
jordan nail it in america doesn't mail
it in okay
you